I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV today
I'm talking with Alan Gura the lead
lawyer in DC vs. Heller the big DC gun
ban case Alan what are the facts of this
case the facts of this case are fairly
simple but quite stark Washington DC
bans all guns in the home there's a
complete ban on the possession of
handguns and also while they allow you
technically at least in theory to have a
rifle or shotgun rifles and shotguns
have to be at all times unloaded and
either disassembled or bound by trigger
lock there's no exception for using them
for home self-defense so if you happen
to have a shotgun for example in the
house and a bad guy breaks in the only
thing you can do that shotgun is perhaps
whack the intruder over the head with it
or throw it at them but having an
operable firearm in Washington DC is a
misdemeanor why why is this case
important why should people who either
aren't interested in owning a gun or
don't live or do business in DC why
should they care well for many years the
the movement to ban private firearms
ownership in the United States has
advocated a theory that the Second
Amendment doesn't actually guarantee you
any individual right to have a gun
whatsoever and in the absence of an
individual constitutional right to have
a gun
government is then free to regulate gun
ownership out of existence sometimes
they do it as in DC bhaiyya by a Fiat
that simply bans guns and sometimes they
do it with the death of the death of a
thousand cuts taxes regulations a scheme
of regulation that basically makes gun
ownership difficult and not impossible
so for us to establish a constitutional
right would prevent the government from
intruding on people's rights throughout
the country the DC gun laws basically
went into effect in 1976 these ultra
restrictive gun gun owning ownership
regulations what effect did that have on
crime well it's tough to say that the DC
gun ban has improved the crime situation
within 15 years of the gun ban the
murder rate had tripled the
crime rate had gone through the roof if
anything we know that criminals in
Washington DC still have guns still
obtain and use guns readily they are
undeterred by it but law-abiding
individuals are defenseless within their
own homes so you know at best it's done
nothing to stop crime it may have
actually made this situation worse
you're representing a number of
plaintiffs could you talk about two of
them in particular dick Heller whose
name is really the case is known by an
shelly parker what is their story why
did they want to own guns okay Shelly
Parker moved into an improving
neighborhood on Capitol Hill a number of
years ago and she found out the
neighborhood was not improving fast
enough
Shelly became very active in the
community trying to call the police
organize the citizens to get the drug
dealers off the off the block the drug
dealers figured out fairly quickly what
the source of their problems was and
started harassing her she had her
security camera broke and she had a
brick through a window she had a man
drive a car into her fence and in fact
at one point she had one of the drug
dealers try to break into her home
screaming you know [ __ ] I'll kill you I
live here too
Shelly thought I think quite reasonably
that she needs to have a gun to defend
herself the police are not always going
to be able to defend her dick Heller has
an interesting story as well he lives in
a crime wracked neighborhood also on
Capitol Hill and during the day however
he does have a gun he has a gun when he
goes to federal buildings and other city
government buildings as well government
installations where he works as a
security guard he's allowed to have a
gun on the job he is what's called a
special police officer of Washington DC
he has full arrest powers and everything
else while he's on the job and they give
him a gun to do his job but when it's
time to clock out the gun has to go in a
safe and he goes home defenseless and is
not allowed to have a weapon at home how
should the Supreme Court role well the
Supreme Court should first recognize
that the Second Amendment guarantees an
individual right that belongs to you and
I ordinary members the American
community to have arms they should also
recognize that handguns as a class of
weapons
clearly fall within the type of arms
they're protected by the Second
Amendment and they should strike down
both the handgun ban as well as the
functional firearms ban how will the
Supreme Court role and the and the
rolling is due at any day any day now
certainly by the end of June 2008 is the
expectation well it's hard to predict
prognosticate the Supreme Court but the
argument went very well I thought at
least it seemed like the court was
conversant with the ideas it was a court
that had had read up on the issue and
and seemed open to to recognizing Second
Amendment rights so I'm optimistic that
the court will reach the correct
decision if the Supreme Court strikes
down the DC gun ban that does not
necessarily mean that the gun gun
control will go away or they could also
tailor it so that it only affects DC is
that right well yes that's true in both
grants first of all we don't have any
absolute rights under the United States
Constitution this will not be the end of
gun control and gun regulation but it
will put a stop to gun laws or it should
put a stop to gun laws that the
government cannot demonstrate an actual
need for and one which is respectful of
individual rights and so I think it
should put the brakes and should impact
certain gun control laws the ones are at
least the least defensible as far as the
laws impact we sued Washington DC
because it's a federal entity we don't
have to deal with the stickier issue of
whether or not the Second Amendment also
binds the state governments that will
have to be left for a future litigation
who who was the most receptive or did
you sense was the most receptive justice
to your arguments when you did oral
arguments it's difficult for me to
comment on individual justices but I
would say that many of the justices
seemed receptive to the idea that the
Second Amendment is a meaningful
individual right and you know there seem
to be broad support on the court at
least as far as we experienced the
argument you're not basing that on nods
because that could just be that they
were falling asleep no one fell asleep
during the argument it was quite a
lively argument and in fact the audio
transcript doesn't really capture the
the full spirit of the event but no it
seemed like the court was open to the
idea and it was it was quite open to a
national what who is your favorite the
Supreme Court justice currently sitting
on the bench I'd like to let you know
that in a few weeks once they will and
your least favorite I suspect we'll have
to wait for that I like them all talk a
little bit about your intellectual life
you and your professional career because
you're 37 so you're pretty young to be
arguing in front of the Supreme Court
you really can you can only go downhill
from here
so try enjoy you know have before that
happens you know tell us a little bit
about where you're from and where what's
your ideological background which are
intellectual heritage sure well I was
born in Israel but I grew up in Los
Angeles California I've always had
libertarian leanings I can't think of
any sort of epiphany or event or issue
that suddenly turned me on to
libertarian philosophy but it's the way
I approach the world I believe that
people should generally be free we mean
government government does have a role
in society but it's a role which which
needs to be reduced from its current
state what happens if you lose the the
case well I hope we don't lose this case
but if we lose the case and that will be
a teaching moment for America I mean we
are gonna have to come to terms with the
fact that that we are losing our rights
at an alarming rate the Fourth Amendment
jurisprudence from the court has been
troubling we've had an executive who has
really quite interesting and expansive
ideas of his authority I think sometimes
administration forgets that the
president is not the commander in chief
of the country he's only the commander
in chief or the Armed Forces I I think
that it's time that people take liberty
seriously we do have a wonderful
Constitution a wonderful Bill of Rights
it protects you know a vast array of
personal freedom and it's it's time I
hope that this case will will sort of
lead us in the other direction perhaps
get courts and judges to reflect
or and and give way to and meaning to
our freedoms Thank You Alan very much
thanks for having me I'm Nick Gillespie
for Reason TV thanks for watching